hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play maze find a
way out of this [ __ ] ah all right it
looks like a maze okay so this is um
[ __ ] whatever I'll try to ignore that
you don't know what that was anyway what
whoa huh
this is something that just caught my
eye research what kiss start off like
that
Oh what was that look like Kerrigan Oh
now okay so that's obviously the wrong
way I don't even see an exit in this
thing all right that's the dead end yep
hey you can't
Oh what was that look at was that holy
crap
alright um so I don't know where I'm
going let's see what point is something
about finding your way out so let me
take it right here that kind of
staircases Ziggy zaggy Ziggy Ziggy
oi oi oi ah that was it just me a second
to realize what that was I was a guy
that was a naked guy like pedaling down
the silliest thing I've ever seen
startled me at first but golly okay so
I'm opening up into these sections of
dial little dotted lines and now I'm not
gonna how do I turn off my light Oh what
uh three two Oh what done oh three two
okay what is that ah zero seven three
two it's more up there zero seven three
two then an arrow pointing that way okay
zero seven three two I don't know what
the objective is I don't know something
gah oh God wrong with me okay good are
these big wall pimples okay it's just
kind of a creepy atmosphere but I'm not
sure what's going on zero seven three
two I'm going back up but let me look in
this section up here on the right I
think there's anything well I mean I
don't know maybe the map says like
there's nothing but Oh
oh go away go away go away what are you
doing what are you doing are you doing
to me are you doing to me what are you
doing to me oh ah I forgot to turn that
off ah it's in this area that break it
oh I don't know what that was okay
that's obviously not a good place all
right let's go left again here the
sections
oh no a whoops go forward in life to God
is getting complicated I have to really
focus and remember where I've been zero
seven three two okay these are the
slashes have Wallace lashes no other
zero seven three two in an arrow
pointing that way what is with that
arrow though here Oh
what done whoa what oh I can mark on the
walls so I know where I've been
ah Bryan the original incarnation of
this you couldn't have a met with you oh
okay man this is an unreliable
flashlight I'm getting kind of creepy
out well I've been creeped out but
freaky okay this goes like this is a
long hallway to a dead end but maybe
there's something down here ah got that
is it like a little hyperactive guinea
pig sound voice I don't even know what
it is I don't know if there's a time
limit I don't know if there's like it
monster in here
okay I mean we going the right way very
wrong way I don't know okay should be a
dead end here but okay ah something
keyhole a keyhole this must be like the
exit or something I just need to find
the key okay all right
my okey dokey
so far it hasn't been too too terrible
does that lady and that weird naked guy
trying to hide his shame okay
left No
[ __ ] I missed it I saw like a hand get
this all leads to the same thing it
doesn't wait what this can't be right
where am i oh I got turned around wait
no unless this is shut up okay this is
nothing here this is a little nook
little Oakland ah what was that this is
different from the map wait this is
different wait where am I
I don't know where I am oh crap oh no
wait no I'm not in this is a different
nook it's up here then it goes long way
to the Nook nope nope turn right and aah
Oh what is that I don't know ooh
I want to go home nobody get out of here
please okay shut up
I really should turn the huh-huh one of
three levers yay looks like kind of like
an again I can't say that the graphics
are absolutely top notch in this but
what can you do it's an indie game
graphics aren't gonna be priority I
don't know it's weird like there are
things out here but I don't really feel
the threat of death so that kind of
takes away better than scare I keep
seeing things flicking in and out of the
corners of my eyes okay let's go left
here and then make another left
god damn it stop that [ __ ] oh god yeah I
got your nose is the yes oh man oh god
okay I'm thinking I'm looking for levers
now listen go that way just yet let me
look around corner man I've been in most
of the area I just haven't found the
levers either that I wasn't looking at
him before shut up god damn I like
breaking hands you're TweetDeck top it
keep doing that's gonna stop being so
scary god this is the same thing it's
the same thing there shouldn't be
anything up here nope no levers okay
yeah I don't know it doesn't really
really feel like anything's you know
after me you're trying to kill me ah
zero seven three two where'd that do did
I get it right those it don't tell me
that wasn't it those it zero seven three
two I remember it i frickin remember
all don't be like that don't be like
that don't be like that don't be like
that
okay well where am I I've been looking I
haven't been looking a wrap
okay um zero seven three two that was it
what is that like some shadow just move
past me I come to the staircase thing
again I might take this and look in this
area whoa
how's different were you looking at
there lady what is this what is this
like some invisible wall here oh I don't
know I'm really not finding levers can't
go forward here seems me man I swear I
went I picked up the code code was right
week old missed it see keep doing it it
becomes less scary where am I I know
wait let me look at this lever never
know ah okay so if this goes this way
and then I take a swing song left and
then I take a swing song left again go
over to the swing song numbers I'll be
in the swing song area there's a swing
song chance to read the code again and I
don't think I got it wrong zero seven
three two unless I was reading it wrong
maybe the arrow means right to left or
left to oh maybe he Ramiz left for right
seven three two zero
it's a year seven three two zero or the
opposite of seven three two zero seven
three two zero seven three two zero or
the opposite of 7:30 ha ha
god damn to look into the map I got
let's look up and there's a naked guy ah
man it's like no no fear of there's no
punishment here there's no zero seven
foot seven three two zero look into the
map analyst and I look down boying
there's naked guy seven three two zero
okay I'm in the wrong place
I need to take a left up here seven
three two zero
I took a laughs and then the car will be
here seven three two zero there we go
there what here we go okay one of this
god damn it just remember remember what
what I can't ah [ __ ] I just marked over
it what was I going to remember I can't
even see the symbols anymore oh I
screwed up bad Oh what did I do wrong
seven three two zero I don't need to
remember that any money it's nothing
here I can't that's not
but why did I have to mark over it
that's stupid
okay uh I don't know I don't know I
can't remember those symbols because I
freaking covered him up oh man just
behind it
nope nothing here a marker that ah been
just about everywhere on this map and I
can't find anything beside ah ah man oh
here oh okay throw nice I was this one
and then it was this one and then it was
this one yeah that was it was it wasn't
it that was it
I remember yes it wasn't a freak effect
sassafras pretty sure that was it it was
that I think that looks like the thing I
covered up but oh I gotta go back I
gotta go back and look at it and really
try to decipher there's only four
possibilities so huh I wish there was a
split I'd be awfully ding-dong damn nice
all right
I'm actually low on time I don't know
I'm gonna try to do this or what
yeah I had it right that's it there's a
loop Ian that all it is is jumpscared
now it's kind of dying down a lot so
they just figure this out and see if I
can do something about it I don't know I
don't know don't judge me
judged okay Bing
that's Bing bong that's ping pong boom
oh you had to flip them okay all right
just see what's in here another lever
three lever one door oh look a key whoa
oh I can finish this up now what got
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what's happening what's happening whoa
what that what was that all about
okay I know where to go now I know where
to go I can actually finish this up so
let me get this all done and then I can
get out of here because this is gonna be
a longer I don't want to break this up
into multiple pieces because it seems
like kind of one-shot deal easiest way
to get theirs go straight across how
this isn't easy but whatever not looking
looking at my map nothing gonna happen
to me
oh look a dog so scaring I really I
don't we go game you did you do are they
Lily Lily do you turn are you let me get
Oh get in amazement
oh man this is literally the longest way
I could possibly go we're getting from
one end of the map to the other isn't
exactly fun times get out
Baudelaire dodo and here we go
this is a long stretch can't see yeah I
can't see it you can't scare me
right you're just loud noises nothing le
all the way to the keyhole hey you got
for me never thought I'd actually finish
this what the don't jump well I don't
think I can jump
okay what what was that oh my oh my word
what was that supposed to be I guess I
wasn't supposed to jump but but what now
what is it that laid me back here are
you kidding me what am I gonna do now I
want to go all the way back alright
that's about it for this um this has
been a maze an interesting little game
here at first ya scared the crap out of
me but then it's just like just
constantly reusing stuff and kind of the
production of you either way it's good a
little thing for being something built
in the uni engine trying to try
something new so I appreciate the
developers trying you know a new a new
method of it so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next video bye bye